good afternoon I am nesto cydia of the
Center for the Study of globalization I
have been kindly invited by professor
Shapiro to be the moderator of this
round table that we are about to start
but before I do that let me express as i
know many people today are expressing
our gratitude and recognition to witness
macmillan to Betty McMillan for all the
extraordinary support that they have
provided over many years to our
University in particular in fostering
the interest the training the education
of students and the research of faculty
in areas of International Studies the
story is very long and I will not repeat
it of course because that is not my duty
professor Shapiro but I really want to
say you thank you it is not only because
of you that we have the Macmillan center
but I should tell you that this great
couple is really at the origin of my own
Center they were the largest benefactors
for the creation of the Center for the
Study of globalization and their
generous support and gave life to our
activities over many years so that is
why I am so pleased and solar and so
grateful to be made of this program that
we have this afternoon that happily has
many chapters it is a real celebration
well but you know economics is the
dismal file right
I am afraid that given the profession
and given the topic we will have to try
to get very serious this afternoon
because my colleagues and I have been
invited to have a conversation about a
topic that it is a very much in the
rather disappointing way in which the
global economy and most of its
constituent parts have been behaving
over the last many years and now we can
say that as we all know starting with
the subprime crisis in 2007 but really
accelerating with the eruption of the
great financial crisis in the fall of oh
wait the global economy has had a rather
disappointing performance it is true
that the Great Depression that some
people were feeling could happen in the
fall of oh it and the early months of 09
didn't happen but it is equally true
that the global economy after recovery
in 2010 has had a very disappointing
performance a very slow growth in
developed countries for a long time on
average global growth went up in 2010
and driven mostly by the performance of
the so-called emerging economies but one
very interesting aspect of these crisis
and its sequel is what happened before
the crisis as typically has happening in
history there was a process of severe
debt accumulation and some of the large
economies of the world and what
economies had studied and observed
historically is that after the eruption
of the crisis the adjustment that has to
be taken in face of the crisis the this
process of debt accumulation will start
to reverse at least gladwin well what
happened is that before the eruption of
the crisis for seven eight years the
ratio of global debt to global product
had grown in more than one fifth which
is huge in such a short period of time
well it is interesting that since the
crisis erupted or since the subprime
crisis started to happen the global debt
to GDP has continued to grow and it has
grown in almost one-fifth and this is a
very worrisome because we were supposed
to be by now digestive that episode of
the debt accumulation and with that the
economies should be having a more
healthy performance than the one we have
observed and in fact the story has
become more complicated in the last
three or four years because as I
mentioned in 2010 the emerging economies
had already started to to be the driver
of the global economy but now that story
is over China is growing considerably
less than it had grown in the 20 25
years before the crisis the new normal
and some people think it is optimistic
for China is growth of six percent I
hear the president of China
two years ago saying we will grow at
seven percent I saw him again again in
november and said well between six and
seven percent i don't know what he would
say next time i have the opportunity to
listen to him but that is not the whole
story the other side of the story is
that over these years post-crisis the
ratio of debt to gdp in china has
quadrupled now China is one of the most
leverage economies in the world but the
story continues countries that used to
be considered also great engines of
global growth like Brazil Brazil last
year and this year is literally in a
state of depression the Brazilian
economy contracted three-point-eight
percent last year and will contract
again the same and the debt to GDP is
also grow in and grow and I could
continue the story but the bottom line
is that we are in trouble and part of
the story is what has happened with debt
and quite frankly we don't really
ambition yet how this vicious cycle of
lack of demand weak growth and
increasing indebtedness in the world is
going to be a stop and there are of
course as many points of view as
economies that are in the world but
basically I would say there are two
broad camps the heterodox camp and the
not so heterodox camp so we have always
these discussions about how to go about
this a question and I don't really know
but i think i am very lucky that this
afternoon i will have the opportunity of
course you will have the opportunity to
listen to three distinguished scholars
who have done outstanding work in at
least areas of concern for the problem
attack we had professor Katherine
Dominguez with a professor of economics
and public policy at the University of
Michigan we have a professor Andrew
metric with the Michael H Jordan
professor at the School of Management
and we have the famous professor
georgene young the populace the game
story professor at the department of
economics and who is as I said one of
the greatest scholars in on these
subjects you know he is the scholar who
has developed visual theory of cycle of
leverage which I think comes very fit to
think about these issues so what i will
do is first to invite professor
Dominguez she has been doing well for a
long time relevant research for our
problem but most recently she has been
thinking about question of exchange
rates and reserves and and this comes
very relevant to a topic because as I
mentioned the problem of emerging
countries and I would say recent work
thought more about the emerging
countries is becoming extremely policy
realm and after that i will go to
Professor metric and then to john g and
then we will have perhaps a brief
interchange and more importantly we will
be awaiting your comments and questions
thank
well thank you for that nice
introduction and I have to say I was
here as a graduate student a century ago
and that was not when there were funds
to send graduate students abroad to do
their research so I feel like I'd need a
do-over I'd like to take advantage of
that this is just a wonderful thing to
have done and I imagine that's really
going to be wonderful for the graduate
students in the future so I have been
working on the question of under what
circumstances governments can manage or
influence their exchange rates and most
of my early work was really looking at
the US and how the u.s. affects the
value of the dollar more recently I've
been looking at this question more from
the point of view of emerging market
countries and the issue of influencing
exchange rates for money many countries
is very much tightly bound with their
decisions about accumulating foreign
reserves so what do I mean by foreign
reserves so we define those as assets
that are denominated in a foreign
currency and that are highly liquid so
in practice what this means for most
countries is holdings of US Treasury
securities or holdings of euro
denominated european bonds so given that
our panel is is discussing a global debt
in some ways for emerging markets
sovereign debt and especially sovereign
debt issued by advanced economies that
in markets that are very liquid are part
of the policy strategy that they use to
manage their exchange rates and indeed
china since you already brought up China
China is the leader of the pack
currently it has about three point two
trillion dollars nobody really knows
those the data is a little sketchy but
it's not all in US Treasury securities
but a good portion of it is they are not
the only country that has a huge arsenal
of foreign reserves most emerging
markets likewise have very have always
had reserves but have really grown those
reserves in the last few years and then
we even have countries like Switzerland
and Japan who have really built up their
foreign reserves in the last few years
in their attempts to try to manage their
their currencies so the idea is of
course if a country wants to forestall
an appreciation or strengthening of
their currency what they're going to be
doing is buying for example US Treasury
securities and selling their own
domestic securities on the market trying
trying to attempt to to bring down it's
already stopped their currency from from
appreciating or strengthening and
importantly it also goes the other way
when a country is trying to forestall
the depreciation or a devaluation of
their currency they're going to use
those reserves as they're sort of
backstop for their currency they're
going to end up selling those reserves
to try to stop the decline in their
currency and we have a lot of examples
in the 1990s in particular a new nurse
joy sorry to stand have to bring up
Mexico here so uh be careful um I'm sure
you had nothing to do with this but uh
but Mexico is often the example used in
the 1990s of a country that had a fairly
sizable reserve portfolio when the the
peso exchange rate was was being
attacked by speculators and they found
much to their distress that their
arsenal was not large enough and in fact
the peso devalued by forty percent
she got you fifty percent sixty percent
sup big big numbers and then we had a
number of countries in East Asia
basically following Mexico's lead later
in the 1990s all being subject to
devaluation attacks all of them
basically having to have given up on
their currency after thinking that they
had a fairly sizable foreign reserve
portfolio and learning that it was not
large enough in the aftermath of those
crises we saw emerging markets take as a
lesson from that experience they needed
to build up their reserve portfolios
even more than they had before and China
again is the leader of the pack but most
other emerging markets have followed
suit and have really built up huge
portfolios of again mostly dollar but
also euro and yen denominated assets
mostly government securities so so then
that brings us up to the global crisis
in 2008-2009 so many of these countries
had built up fairly sizeable portfolios
of assets these were kind of like a
rainy day fund of sorts if if a country
was in crisis they had this large
portfolio of assets that they could
presumably use both both to suggest to
investors that they would be able to
hold on to the value of their currency
but also that they had resources in in
times of crisis so I I did quite a bit
of work after the crisis to look to see
whether or not countries that had really
built up sizable reserve portfolios
whether or not they actually fared
better than countries that had not gone
that route had not built up quite as
large reserves and and the story is a
happy one for China at least in that
case that in fact it looks like many of
the countries that did in fact build up
fairly large reserve portfolios did do
better during the crisis seemed to
handle the crisis better
than countries that did not so on an
individual country-by-country basis it
looks like countries actually did better
by having built up reserves we can talk
sort of more generally about whether or
not on a global basis it's a good idea
for countries to feel the need to build
up these large reserve portfolios in
part to try to convince speculators that
in fact they'll be able to hold on to
the value of their currency so that I'll
hold that question out for for QA but I
think it's an interesting one so so let
me get a move move forward in time to to
where we are now so as I Ernesto
suggested total accumulated debt global
debt currently is higher than it was at
the start of the crisis and the
countries that have really been the big
drivers of this large increase in global
debt this time are the emerging markets
and again China is probably the leader
of the pack its current debt to GDP
ratio is fairly comparable to the
debt-to-gdp ratio in the United States
and Europe but it's sizably higher than
it was prior to the crisis so two things
one is the size and because China so
large it has really on a de to the
global debt levels but also the
trajectory just how quickly debt levels
have increased in China the other aspect
of the current situation which I find
really interesting is it's not Chinese
government debt that that has been built
up its its private sector debt in China
and in particular it's not it's
non-financial non banking firms that
have built up the dead and so there's a
very open question so if it's a
government that's built up debt we have
a number of different ways we could
imagine a government deciding to to
respond to that to a
crisis it's a little bit less clear what
the role of the Chinese government would
be if in fact a number of the companies
with these high debt levels find
themselves unable to service the debt
there's there's nothing that says that
the Chinese government would necessarily
bail out those firms and they certainly
have the resources to do so but exactly
how they would go about it is is an open
question which I think a lot of people
are concerned about not knowing how
exactly that might play out so so
actually that is an area that my current
research is really focused on is when
the debt levels are really coming from
the private sector and not are not
sovereign debt we've had lots of
experience with sovereign debt crises
and we have ideas about what what might
transfigure trans what it exactly
happens and what the stages are we're a
little bit less there has been less
experience with what happens if most of
the debt is private sector debt and
exactly how how the weather not reserves
might be brought into play to bail out
the firms and exactly how how the whole
process might play out so I'll stop
there and and and maybe we can talk more
about this in the QA thank you very much
undo this room is big enough for a
microphone leave the microphone aside
and see if people have any trouble
hearing me I'm going to talk about our
panels global debt and one of the
connections to it which would be
financial stability and the relationship
between those two things or more broadly
between debt and financial stability
which is a very important connection the
most important connection probably the
most important predictor for financial
stability and it's going to be I think
quite closely related to some of the
things that Katherine discussed we've
run a lot of regression so we've done a
lot of statistical analyses
to figure out what predicts whether a
financial crisis happens and these are
worldwide cross country studies over
long time periods there's one main
result that always comes out which is
that high levels of debt or or leverage
John's language predict financial crises
there's other sub results in there
that's the only big one and we're
learning more recently while it's
short-term debt seems to be a better
more important predictor than overall
debt perhaps mortgage debt is a most
important component of overall debt that
predicts financial crises but it's dead
and when you particularly when you get
an acceleration in the debt levels and
these are country by country that's when
you see a much higher likelihood of a
crisis so people have understood this
intuitively for a long time and and
there have been I would say case studies
of people studying this back for a while
only in recent years do we have the kind
of data sets that enable us to test
these things more precisely
reinhart-rogoff did a lot of important
work recently alan taylor and a variety
of colleagues have constructed a
fantastic data set with historical data
going back to the late 19th century
across depending on how long you want to
go far back 14 and 20 of the largest
countries in the world all giving these
same predictors and so that means we
know we need to understand why does that
happen why do we see these increases in
debt and there's two main intellectual
traditions I would say one that is an
older intellectual tradition that has
recently had some fantastic work think
anchored by a janji here to my right
which is on let's call it the demand
side for funds so people who want to be
able to borrow in order to be able to
invest so a lot of this is driven by
expectations of high future returns it
tends to be equity driven debt a lot of
times so you want to invest and you need
to borrow a lot of money because you
have a limited equity cool to be able to
make that investment or if you're going
to end up holding the debt you're just
convinced everything's going to go
swimmingly in the future and your debt
will be worth 100 cents on the dollar it
tends to be related very much to the
study of bubbles and it's one very
important side of the equation and it's
one that that people been talking about
for a long time but I would say only
recently are we starting to see models
that are very satisfying start starting
with John's the other piece to it which
is a somewhat more recent area of study
and it is there's contributors from
finance for macro economics from
international finance Katherine coming
from those last two categories right
right in this area which is coming let's
say more about the supply of funds or
the demand for what those funds can be
built into in terms of bonds Katherine
talked about how when emerging markets
such as China we also saw it in the
Middle East build up surpluses they
really like to hold a lot of those
things in stuff that's safe something
they don't have to think about it really
economize Azaan your information
production to just be able to hold debt
that's safe debt Ben Bernanke talked in
the mid-2000s before the crisis about
there being perhaps a global savings
glut and he was speaking about that in
the context of why it might be they were
doing all these things with short rates
but long rates weren't moving there's a
lot of people who are demanding nice
safe debt but the broader bigger picture
is that the huge demands for the safe
debt so it's not coming from people who
necessarily want to invest in new real
projects and have great expectations
about the future but people who are
sitting around with a lot of cash one
put some of it in a super safe checking
account and the safest checking account
is the debt of sovereigns like the
United States like the UK that's where
they want to put their money so the guys
hates you okay need to kind of produce
some of that in to the extent that they
don't the private markets need to
produce a substitute we're going to talk
a little bit about that side of the
equation this supply side of the debt
where it might come from and how the
financial system has changed over the
last
60 years in a way that now it makes the
regulation for central bankers for
people who look at large bags a very
different type of problem and a more
complicated problem than we used to have
and that's that's the area that I'm
focused on now and so I still have more
questions than answers but let me tell
you about give you a few facts and then
talk about some of those questions are
so the first the first set of facts i've
alluded to which is alan taylor and his
co-authors and reinhart-rogoff findings
that it is a debt that predicts
financial crises and i think maybe a
more important result from taylor's work
is that if you look up until World War
two across all the largest economies the
amount of you can either call it debt in
the economy or the other side of the
balance sheet the assets of banks to be
very close to being the the debt the
private debt that was in economies at
the time that that tracked very closely
the old milton friedman style measures
of the money supply the world look kind
of the same didn't really matter you
could look at money supply or you could
look at debt / assets in the economy and
you would get similar kinds of
predictions and either one of those
things could predict what was going to
go on in the macro economy and whether
you had a financial crisis post-world
war two those things have completely
decoupled we've seen a huge
financialization in the world economy in
terms of the total amount of assets that
are out there or bank debt that's out
there different size of the balance
sheet even / gdp whereas the money
supplies ratio with gdp is stayed
relatively constant and indeed it is the
debt side that is the predictor of stuff
including financial crises whereas the
monetary predictors don't seem to work
well anymore so we've seen a change in
the world overall kind of cross country
studies looking just at the united
states where the data on individual
components of this financialization are
much better Federal Reserve's been doing
a better job than our European friends
and I yell at my European friends dump
is that things like flow of funds so we
can decompose things is that if we go
back to nineteen fifty two and you trace
starting with tryna understand the
financialization in the economy you'll
see that their ratio of total financial
total financial asset total assets not
financial assets total assets in the
economy to GDP went from four to 12
almost ten to one there's a lot more
assets we have a kind of more asset
intensive economy the financial assets
to GDP so financial assets or a subset
of total assets your house is an asset
but the mortgage on it is financial
asset will be some double counting that
goes on here financial assets have gone
from about 1 times gdp to four and a
half times GP so they're nearly had they
were about a quarter of all assets in
1952 and by now they're like almost a
half so there's been this huge change in
overall asset intensity and how much it
gets used and the fraction of another
financial assets during that same time
period where the financial assets have
grown tremendously we don't see anything
it looks like a stable world in terms of
its use of assets the percentage of
those ask of all financial assets that
you could call loosely safe assets think
of things that get ratings of triple-a
government debt triple-a mortgage
securities when we thought those were
triple-a agency debt money market mutual
funds add all of that up divide it by
the total amount of assets which
remember financial assets which have
been exploding and you get a number that
is almost exactly thirty three percent
plus or minus one or two percent almost
every year going back to nineteen fifty
two so while the world has been changing
I'm in this crazy way in our use of
financial assets the fraction of them
that are safe or kind of something that
we would call safe has stayed relatively
constant almost like you need to have
you know if you're a country and you
have a whole lot of reserves you know
some fraction of them just need to be in
something you don't have to think about
just like we're all told keep a certain
amount of our portfolio in cash and a
certain amount in stocks the composition
however of what we call safe assets has
changed remarkably so this island of
stability which is the fraction of all
has financial assets that are safe but
the composition of has changed
tremendously in nineteen fifty to eighty
percent of what we would call safe
assets were deposit sitting in banks and
in that kind of world if you tell a bank
what to do and you give rules for banks
or you break up banks you do whatever
you want to back you could have a very
large effect on what's going on in the
financial system because there any
percent of what where people are getting
their safety by the time of the
financial crisis it was less than forty
percent was coming from banks and sixty
percent from other places and what are
those other places securitized bonds
often mortgage-backed securities money
market mutual funds which had grown to a
four trillion dollar industry as
compared to 10 trillion dollars on the
balance sheets of banks on the eve of
the crisis a lot of things that are
asset-backed commercial paper for
example things that are substitutes in
some sense for the super safe stuff that
we can have in in in bags and in fact at
very short horizons you see exactly that
so if China suddenly gets an influx of
cash for whatever reason because they're
running a large budget surplus and they
put that in u.s. government in agency
securities the people who used to have
those US government agency securities
would like to demand the data tell us a
substitute for them that's also nice and
safe and you can see it very short
horizons for example that if the US
government because it had a lot of tax
receipts in a week issues less debt that
week for reasons totally exogenous to
the financial system you see more
issuance that week of asset-backed
commercial paper more issuance that week
of mortgage-backed securities that pull
together mortgages that have been
sitting in warehouses for a long time
the financial system is very very good
at manufacturing safe assets when the
market demands it and a lot of what we
saw happen in the build-up to the
financial crisis was coming from this
side you need to have both as marshal
marshals of famous economist from the
early 20th century and you talked about
demand and supply is the two sides two
pieces of
users and I'm done youngji gets very mad
with a colleague who steals his tan okay
I'm done oh the finishing point was this
is a rich rich area of study right now
is trying to understand in a world where
the borders between banks and all other
financial institutions are thin and you
go back and forth real fast what do you
do as a central banker to regulate to
manage the money supply to manage the
amount of leverage that's in the economy
okay thank you so I'm going to continue
with what both previous speakers were
discussing and as I Ernesto said you
know the vast majority of crises are
tied to debt and the last two we've seen
with a subprime mortgage crisis in the
US and now the European crisis the
sovereign debt crisis going on in Europe
that's had a horrible effect especially
in southern Europe and the mortgage
crisis by the way in America as you know
caused what's it's called the great
recession the worst financial downturn
since the Great Depression debt also
causes individual problems as anyone
who's a student at Yale is fully aware
of student debt but that's also
historically an extremely important
topic Islam doesn't permit lending it
interest the Bible talks over and over
about the harms of lending at interest
Shakespeare talked about lending at
interest Nietzsche explained in the
genealogy of morals that morality itself
is due to the concept of death the
german word for debt jeweled is you know
should it's also the word for conscience
and german the old word for conscience
many famous rulers have forgiven debt
Hammurabi forgave death the Babylonian
so lonely lawgiver in Athens gave
forgave debt Caesar forgave debt as as a
Yale sociologist who's no longer here
pointed out the rosetta stone you know
everyone knows about the rosetta stone
what was so important about it that it
had to be translated into three
languages
is why we know what hieroglyphics are
because it's translated into demotic you
know Egyptian and whatever it is ancient
and to Greek why did they have to
translate into three languages while
they were forgiving debt and they wanted
everybody to know you know so
philosophers and throw those told me the
fifth philosophers anthropologists
historians political scientists
economists they're all even
mathematicians who talked about the
predictors of crises even mathematicians
are trying to figure out what's the
signature of debt so it's not so
surprising that we've started a program
in global debt here and are dead anyway
at the Macmillan Center and hopefully it
will bring together a lot of different
people from different fields you can
study debt and all its different aspects
now debt is the engine of growth but
it's also the cause of our worst
financial crises so it's not so
surprising that the most powerful
institutions at least financial
institutions many of any kind of
institution are the central banks
they've got to manage the debt and
balance this growth versus avoiding
catastrophe but obviously they're doing
something wrong we've had too many
catastrophes so what is it that they do
wrong well the first thing is if you
just read the newspapers they're always
talking about the interest rate you know
when when when the crisis happened the
subprime crisis Brennan Bernanke lowered
the interest rates 20 they're still
basically 0 for 7 years we've had the
interest rates at zero and now they're
talking about well maybe the economy is
going to pick up so they're going to
raise the interest rates are lower the
interest rates they're going to raise
the interest rates that's what the
central bank does it manages the
interest rates but there's a lot more
debt than the interest rate there's the
terms of the debt when you borrow money
as Angelus talking about in the mortgage
the cause of the central predictor he
was saying and all his different kinds
of debt you don't worry about just what
the the interest rate is in the mortgage
we're about how much you can borrow on
the house can you borrow eighty percent
of it or ninety percent of it uuu the
bank wants to know your FICO score if
your company borrowing money they want
to know your credit rating I don't know
if you could put a picture up so how is
it that that never comes up in the
newspapers about the central bank's how
can they never talk about what I call
the credit surface oh you got that too
while you pee he said anyway I had
somehow compressed the picture into a
little dot not giving up in despair and
it was willing to bet his raise that he
could not be so I hope they give you a
generous one anyway this is a picture of
all the Fannie and Freddie loans from
2013 if you look at the FICO score of
every single borrower you can see it go
like you even read it's 800 in the near
corner and lower number 6 50 in the far
corner and loan to value is really bad
ninety-five percent in the hundred
percent in the far corner and fifty
percent in the near corner so you see
just these are the best borrowers in
America you see I averaged over all of
them in little buckets and you know me
the best fit you see that in the near
corner they pay a very low interest rate
when they're high high credit quality
and and lots of collateral they pay very
low interest rate as the credit quality
goes bad they pay a higher interest rate
what could be a simpler idea every
business person you know takes this into
account in making alone alone is about
trust is the guy reliable earn the
borrow reliable or not reliable the less
reliable the higher the interest rates
going to be when they say credit
conditions are tight what do they mean
not that the interest rates higher whoa
you know in the newspapers or with the
Fed making pronouncements you've got no
idea what it means but what they what
they ought to mean is that the credit
surfaces steam you know the most
interesting borrowers are the ones who
are doing something a little bit risky
so they're going to be charged a higher
interest rate as that steepness goes up
that's the sign that credit conditions
are tight and the flatter it gets that's
a sign that credit is easy and people
are going to be borrowing a lot of money
to do a lot of all kinds of things some
of which will might be very good and
someone which might be more risky okay
so the next thing so we've got to pay
attention to the terms of credit not
just the interest rate the next thing is
that the terms of credit affect prices
of assets and Joe is saying why is it
that the amount of debt and stuff like
that is a good predictor well you know
one of the things he measuring either
directly or indirectly is the loan to
value the ratio of the amount borrowed
to the value of the collateral
backing it or to income backing it as
that number gets higher that means
people are willing to loan at easier
conditions that's an incredibly good
predictor of asset prices in fact they
almost go simultaneously it's amazing
that people hardly anybody talked about
this twenty years ago there if you could
find a few actually famous economic
historians who talked about it but aside
from them and who pays attention to
economic historian sorry besides I don't
like it I like the story it almost never
came up in models or anything like that
but that's a fundamental relationship
terms of credit getting easier it means
people can borrow money to buy assets
the asset prices go up there is a sign
of something that's getting heated or
maybe over he's in the economy tuition
it's a big mystery why do I has tuition
skyrocket in America so much in the last
15 years you know it's an astronomical
increases while the government made it
possible to borrow to go to school it's
you know it's like the leverage on going
to school on Colleges went way up and so
the prices of tuition went way up ok now
I am running out of time so let me talk
about forgiveness so debt overhang as
Katherine and Ernesto pointed out that's
a real cause of why the economies
languish after one of these debt
explosions and crises we just never know
how can you get out of debt overhang by
forgiving some of the debt by admitting
you're not going to get it back and
forgiving the part that you weren't
going to get any way but we never gave
forgave debt in the subprime crisis it's
astonishing we didn't forgive debt a
house that was worth maybe it was worth
a lot it fell in value to a hundred
thousand but the loan is still there at
160,000 worth way more than the house of
course the subprime borrowers going to
default so we could have forgiven 160
down to 90 you know and less than the
value of the house probably would have
gotten the 90 back instead none of it
was forgiven not a single penny of
subprime debt was forgiven so the
homeowner hung on and hung on didn't pay
his mortgage didn't pay his taxes didn't
fix the house the average recovery and
all subprime loans was twenty-five
percent 40,000 in that case instead of
getting the 90 because we hung on and
didn't forgive we got 40 okay the
Europeans haven't forgiven the official
set
hasn't forgiven debt in Europe yet even
though it's obvious some of those
countries can't pay so why is it well
the central bank's they don't even
acknowledge that they might not get the
money back they only have a language to
say it when they mark their positions
the positions are marked as if they're
going to get all the money back of
course if you mark alone at 160 you know
and you forgive it down to nine you have
to take a dramatic loss but if you would
recognize from the beginning you were
only going to get 40 you could mark it
at 90 forgive it down to 90 and you'd be
making money not losing money that's the
reason why they don't forgive debt so
let's take the example of Greece that's
going to end with this so III my
family's Greek so I've tried a little
bit too I've consulted a little bit with
the Greek government about trying to get
their debt forgiven very good job has it
got so else nothing's been think of it
but anyway let's take a cape let's take
America's as a good example after World
War Two America had this horrendous debt
from the world war one hundred four
percent debt to GDP amazingly we paid it
down to twenty three percent by 1973
that's one of the great achievements of
whatever generation it's called with
something generation they're so great
anyway so they in there you know they
paid it down but we owed all the debt to
ourselves we had a booming economy with
under five percent unemployment most of
that time even down to the threes we had
a young population Greece has a two
hundred percent almost debt to GDP it
owes it all to foreigners it has a
24-point four percent unemployment it's
been over twenty percent for four and a
half years it's got a currency that's
frozen in the euro so I can't devalue
its currency if it did devalue its
currency would mean the debt would go up
because the you know the value of the
drachma would be lower so the same debt
would be worth much more so it's got
like a three hundred percent debt-to-gdp
ratio it's got a horribly aging
population and it's got a refugee crisis
but they're not forgiving the debt yet
so what is the plan in greece greece is
supposed to pay back the IMF is
calculated in june there's this terrible
negotiation and greece threatened to do
all sorts of things like
leave the euro and then back down and
embarrassingly gave up on its threats
and so they agreed to pay three point
five percent of their gdp as debt
payments for 30 or 40 years that's how
are they going to pay back the debt the
primary surplus now but you know the
surplus that they have to pay a zero
percent now they're going to need
they've just agreed on a huge tax
increase with the IMF to get to 1.5% and
they're going to happen they're about to
have this voted in Parliament any day
now and then on top of that they've got
to raise more taxes to get it to
three-point-five percent they're being
asked to raise conditional taxes if
things you know to promise now that
you'll raise a tax later if such and
such happens and it's not even clear its
Lee anyway that's where the negotiation
is now no free country in history has
paid three and a half percent of its gdp
for 30 years to foreigners that's why I
say free country for six consecutive
years if we show the next next picture
the the IMF has made predictions so at
the low point of you can see the years
at the low point of each of these curves
the IMF's that all things are bad
they're going to get better very soon so
of course you can pay a big percentage
and you can see that every year are
things instead of turning up they
actually turned down now we're at this
bottom thing we're again last June they
were predicting that was going to go
right up and so Greece could pay this
three-point-five percent well the fact
is things haven't gone up and even the
IMF has realized that and they say okay
enough is enough 1.5% is all that they
can pay and since that won't cover the
debt that's outstanding the European
should forgive the debt so that 1.5%
does cover it so why don't they forgive
it well they never forgive it it's just
no one forgives subprime debt in America
the Europeans are forgiving diffusing to
forgive the Germans anyway are refusing
to forgive there are others too but uh
so but some of them want to forgive but
why what's the argument for not
forgiving well promise is a promise how
can we you know you don't want to report
losses to Parliament now that's the same
Bank yours problems not marking things
down you don't want to give Greece a
deal that others who could pay would
demand those are the reasons for not to
give forgive so the question is how do
you construct a deal where the Greeks
think their debt is
forgiving but the Europeans can say what
we didn't forget so that's all right so
there are two ideas going to end with
this two ideas here one is to stop the
constant renegotiations where things
always turn out to be worse than
expected of course they can't do what
they're supposed to have done and then
there's a huge you know huge
renegotiation everybody's screaming and
everybody make a plan that they can do
so make the debt payment contingent on
how the country's doing on what
unemployment is so for example if
unemployment's over twenty five percent
which it has been you don't have to pay
anything back and every time
unemployment drops a little you have to
pay more so maybe point one percent of
surplus gets paid every time
unemployment drops a percents if you go
from twenty five to ten you drop fifteen
percent that's one and a half percent of
GDP you have to pay then in in your debt
payments or maybe you can make it a
little tougher on the Greeks and and
make it go up a little faster but the
first idea is the think we should have
to pay shouldn't depend on when bonds
are coming due and stuff like that it
should depend and not even a fixed
number it should depend on how
unemployment's doing if the country's
crushed it can't pay and you're just
going to get the same renegotiation all
the time it seems like a simple idea
that's the first thing then the second
thing is if you do this plan that's a
lot less even than the one point five
percent you know forever starting right
now that the that the IMF is asking for
if you do that Greece will never pay off
its debt it's you know you can't have a
country that's permanently in debt
they're not going to pay off anyway so
how do you balance this get the Germans
to forgive while thinking they're not
forgiving yet so they have to recognize
that eventually they won't get the money
back or they'll never give anything so
if they recognize that which I'm sure
they do here's a suggestion every time
Greece actually pays a dollar you count
it as three dollars so you pay back a
dollar you get to forget you know the
doll you pay back and you also get
forgiven two more dollars now Brie's can
immediately say we got two-thirds of our
debt written off but the Germans who
don't think the Greeks are going to pay
anything back because they know they
have
yeah there they don't you know they
don't have to do it until the money
comes in so they can forgive very slowly
and they actually have to get cash in
their hands before they forgive anything
they're getting something and now if
you're a Greek thinking of selling off
an island you're not going to do it if
the debt is infinite you're just going
to give away an island that's going to
pay infinity to infinity minus Epsilon
but if you think you can actually pay
the debt down you might see them doing a
lot more dramatic things and they've
done yet and actually getting the
country galvanized so well when we
engage in Michael solutions which
sometimes are needed is that we are in
deep trouble okay right and I think that
is the issue right now when we think
about the process that could unravel to
china for example or even any other
major economy because of this debt
overhang well the problem of Greece
which is a very serious not only
economic but also a human problem and we
look as a truly minor problem because
the human caused economic costs that we
have seen in Greece will be multiplied
manifold so I don't know whether the
demand-driven bill or the supply driven
view is right but today we have a very
serious problem and I think our
responsibility in addition to think hard
about what happened in history to
produce better models with the better
explanatory power and try to see whether
the rice there they are sustained
empirically is to push a little bit
harder
towards possible policy solutions
because the program as we have discussed
here is not getting better and more and
more we see paralysis from the part of
government institutions to address these
issues we are really in a vicious cycle
where economies don't grow debts don't
come down and therefore the size of the
dead relative to the size of the economy
is getting worse so the question is do
we need to go rather sooner than later
through another major crisis that
probably would be worse than the
previous one before institutions react
and take the necessary decisions or this
model true the problem at the end is
going to provide a escape speed and make
and somehow the processes of adjustment
will allow economies to finally start
roll well who knows but what we also
know is that there are some structural
conditions particularly in developed
economies that may point out to the fact
that irrespective of any improvement in
financial conditions those economies may
be prone today to less grow and let much
less than in the past and that's a big
problem because precisely at a time that
we need more grow the demographics and
probably the stagnation in productivity
growth will play against the growth of
the overall economy
so that means that the effort has to be
even bigger and I say these to confirm
to you that this is that this month
science and so I don't owe you any of
you want to make a comment and what you
at your desk upset or we should open the
floor now I think we should open the
floor to questions or comments at this
point anybody wants to give a note of
optimism you will have an extra drink
thank you I haven't a question for a
John John a coupla so you said that the
whole situation with the Greek debt is a
promise is a promise that's what their
justification is for not forgiving the
debt right and indeed the whole debate
has moral and even religious
connotations sometimes right so Greece
failed and it has to pay for its
original sin and it has to suffer even
though if it suffers nobody really wins
but anyway so I'm asking what when is
this original sin actually when did it
take place wasn't in 2012 with the
haircut on the Greek debt back then that
that was held by private banks across
the world or mostly Europe and then
suddenly it became from an economic it
became a political issue when Greece got
locked into the official sector and then
if we if we have to like assess that all
of the IMF algae as you showed they have
failed miserably in making predictions
about the future if the IMF's mandate is
to help countries in distress into
balancing the budget right and making
the lives of their citizens better in
went in cases where the debt has risen
so high the fact that the IMF actually
intervenes in favor of the creditors and
not in favor of helping a country reach
debt forgiveness then how is its mandate
served nowadays thank you
okay I'll risk for the question i'll
respond to both of them so the the a lot
of the Greek debt was oh a lot of French
and German banks had you know how did
Greece getting so much debt a lot of
French and German banks lent them a huge
amount of money and they were already
having problems with the American
subprime stuff that they had bought and
now on top of that the Greeks were going
to default against them and so the
bailout basically bailed out the the
European bailout among other things
bailed out the French and German banks
and replaced you know they the the
official sector stood in place of the
French and European banks and then
Greece owed the money to the official
sector instead of to the private sector
now the private sector you know what was
left of the private sector the private
sector has taken a haircut you know a
lot of private lenders they lost around
fifty percent of they forgave fifty
percent of the money the official sector
hasn't forgiven anything so why is it
that the official sector that you would
think of would be more merciful and more
reasonable more benevolent because
they're not just profit oriented they
want the harmony of Europe you would
think they would be kinder and wiser
than the private sector well it turns
out that you know the the profit motive
you know it's pretty good motive for
getting people to make reasonable
decisions when you take the profit
motive out of it you sometimes get less
merciful decisions so in the American
subprime mortgage crisis 17 hedge funds
testified in Congress that they wanted
to forgive the debt it would make more
money for them to forgive the debt but
they weren't allowed to forgive the deck
as they couldn't coordinate the
government didn't step in to help them
coordinate to forgive the debt so the
private sector is often better than the
official sector but this is a failure of
governance this is something that
hopefully work at places like the
Macmillan Center will solve there'll be
some some way of thinking about it so
the official sector can get better now
the IMF has been a disaster but actually
they're Greece's best friend now in a
way they're being very tough on the
Greeks but they're the only ones who are
saying unequivocally the debt should be
forgiven Greece can't pay it we declare
as our expert opinion Greece cannot pay
the debt and the you know the
any of the Europeans agree with them
privately but haven't said it publicly
and there's some Europeans who don't
agree with them think Greece can pay it
so actually I think the trick in these
negotiations is to marshal the IMF on
behalf of Greece and they're being
incredibly difficult with Greece now
they're trying to prove a point they
want grease to confess that it can't
make the three point five percent the
Greeks feel duty-bound to keep their
word and say we can make the three point
five percent and once you see us do it
then you'll forgive the debt but but you
know it's a little bit crazy that
posture what catch-22 yeah they want to
show that they're good guys and they've
keeping their promise but once they show
what the Germans are going to say well
you can pay it so so so the IMF is
actually going to play a crucial role
here I think in getting the debt
forgiven if it does get forgiven so I
think they learned a lesson this is an
incredibly embarrassed look at that that
couldn't I mean what you know dismal
science and this is just embarrassing
where every year they were wrong thirty
percent mistake I mean you can't make
thirty percent mistakes over a couple
years it's incredibly embarrassing so of
course they've they're going to be
better now I hope we have time for just
one more question this is perhaps both
professor Dominguez you had indicated
that global debt is higher than it was
during the financial crisis can you
elaborate a bit on the role of the
ratings agencies you know are when they
issue their reports on the different
countries are they only looking on the
on the government debt or also on the
private lay health dead and so how are
we going you know if they are not doing
their job how are we going to get this
issue under control so the credit rating
companies do both rate the private
sector as well as sovereigns but it is
an interesting question there they're
not really looking at the overall
picture they're looking at specific
issuers of debt and telling us whether
or not their credit worthy or not now
that we've moved to most of the are the
large increase in debt since the
financial crisis is mostly from emerging
markets where as obviously before the
crisis it was more from from the
advanced economies and it tends much of
it is not not all of it but much of it
is private sector debt so again it gets
tricky because you could have a
different different credit ratings for
different companies within a country and
then just to make things even more
complicated a goodly number of these are
in China where kind of corporate
governance kinds of and transparencies
is less less clear than it might be in
other country so i don't know that
answering your question but the part of
the issue is that the the build-up of
debt has been more from the private
sector than the government sector in
this most recent period well thank you
very much unfortunately we have to
conclude the session just let me say
that one element that perhaps would
deserve a different and additional
session will be the topic of
international coordination I think these
crises happen to some extent but not
only because countries fail to
coordinate before the crisis erupted to
prevent the huge disick elyria that was
happening during those years when the
crisis came they came together into the
g20 and in November of 2008 first point
was to recognize that the lack of
coordination the lack of coherence among
these countries was at least part of the
explanation of the crisis they pledged
to coordinate
and indeed they coordinated at the
beginning I think that prevented the
first great oppression of the 21st
century tucson AZ 10 the central banks
have kept some degree of coordination
there has been some coordination through
the financial stability board for
aspects of financial reforms but not so
much basically US and Europe upon the
wrong way and the uke okay the idea of
coordination has practically disappeared
from the g20 and I think the fact that
this is happening will make much harder
to deal with these issues the question
that john g has raised about europe and
the specific topic of greece well i
think fundamentally it's a problem of
macroeconomic policy coordination the
Germans have been worse than the shinies
before the crisis in accumulating huge
current account surpluses and today by
any measure they are much worse because
Germany has a current account surplus of
seven percent of GDP and that is a
source of serious disequilibrium and as
john g said nobody's really talking
about the tackle some of the root causes
of this issue because simply some
countries want to free right on the
actions of others we mean we were going
to live in a globalized economy in a
globalized or with a globalized
financial system we need international
coordination which i think it's a big
topic for our mud million center thank
you very much
you